salut tout le monde comment est ce que
vous allez alors regardez aujourd'hui on
est à la maison on est à la maison pour
parler d'une télé ça résonne un peu chez
moi pourtant ces meublés mais ça résonne
on se parle d'une télé nouvelle télé de
hisense alors la référence je vous la
donne elle est dans le titre est la
description mais je voulais te donne
quand même face et une 55 pouces elle
existe en différentes dimensions 55e 7h
cubes si vous voulez un écran culêtre
culêtre c'est quoi ce sont des led avec
du quantum dots enfin bref super
intéressant pour avoir des noirs plus
profonds pour avoir à quelque chose de
lumineux pour avoir de bonnes couleurs
vous avez cette télé et ça permet de
rentrer dans le cul l'aide chez icesave
et je vous lis tout de suite parce qu'il
ya des offres c'est aujourd'hui une
vidéo qui est réalisé en partenariat
avec high side by side soit il tient
monsieur bref ça m'intéresserait de
présenter ce téléviseur et il est
évident que cette année c'est une année
de coupe du monde de football d'ailleurs
à snc partenaire premium de la coupe du
monde de football au qatar et quand qui
a des années de coupe du monde on aime
bien changé renouvelle ses téléviseurs
donc là vous avez des offres hyper canon
en modèle 50 poussettes et les coûte 499
euros et du 22 juin au 19 juillet vous
avez 50 euros de remboursés sur cette
télévision là ça vous le sort à 449
euros c'est plutôt pas mal et sur un
modèle à 55 pouces et celui que j'ai
l'âge 65 pouces 599 euros et vous avez
100 euros de remboursés a directement ça
vous sur votre téléviseur à 499 faudra à
peu près 500 euros vous avez ce
téléviseur [ __ ] aide chi'ites en forme
à 55 pouces donc on va essayer
aujourd'hui de décortiquer voir ce qu'on
peut faire avec ce téléviseur voir ce
qu'il vous propose comprendre un peu les
différentes fonctionnalités et
l'expérience aussi bien évidemment avec
une jolie télécommande avec un assistant
des assistants vocaux avec une
expérience vaut qu'on y va aujourd'hui
c'est parti pour découvrir cette
nouvelle télé 55 pouces culotte de
hisense
[Musique]
première chose à voir c'est le design
qu'on va venir retrouver c'est à dire
d'abord qui vont être extrêmement fins
bord très fin au plat sur le aux bords
fins sur le bas vous avez des pieds qui
viennent se visser vous avez deux vis de
chaque côté elle est très légère elle
fait 18 kilos et demi donc très facile à
venir installer ça c'est cool petit
branding hisense que vous allez
retrouver au centre juste là avec le
récepteur par télécommande infrarouge
voyez on a débord qui sont très très
faim ça permet d'avoir un design qui est
très léger et ça c'est très très
chouette ans sur un télé comme ça 55
pouces c'est quand même hyper hyper cool
c'est également une télé qui est très
fine si vous regarder de ce côté là à
regarder ans mais de profil c'est
extrêmement fin donc si vous la poser
sur un meuble vous êtes quand même
vachement bien là de ce côté là vous le
voyez vous avez votre prise pour venir
la branche et objectivement sur le
secteur et si on fait le tour de l'autre
côté et qu'on regarde ce qui se passe
vous allez avoir toutes les connectiques
dont vous avez besoin on a trois demis
2.1 dans un hangar ces deux usb sortie
audio s/pdif entrée audio droite-gauche
prise casque 2 prise antenne une entrée
composite et une énergie 45 punition
brossé noir elle est super élégante elle
est très fine très légère très légère en
poids très légère en design bref pour
avoir un beau téléviseur dans votre
intérieur c'est très cool la seule chose
à savoir c'est d'avoir le bon peuple qui
va bien pour avoir l'écartement parce
que les pieds vous les avez uniquement
dans cette position n'y a pas de caisse
centrale ici mais quand on veut un
téléviseur comme ça il faut le meuble
qui va avec pour que normalement ça
devrait bien se passer alors moi je veux
qu'on parle de cette dalle parce que
comme je vous le disais c'est l'entrée
de gamme du cul les chipsets le cul
l'aide c'est vachement cool ici on est
sur la 4k uhd je vous le dis c'est le
modèle en 55 pouces mais elle existe en
différentes tailles à vous de voir ce
qui conviendra le mieux chez vous à
savoir qu'ici vous avez plus d'un
milliard de nuances de couleurs ça
d'écran qui est certifié dolby vision
jeudi à 10 plus tout ça va nous apporter
des qualités en termes de luminosité de
contraste de netteté de couleurs alors
attention on est sur du cul les dons
arrivent dans le cul l'aide on n'est pas
dans les clubs les plus haut de gamme
qu'on va retrouver chez hisense ici mais
ça vous permet de mettre un pied dedans
avec un téléviseur qui est quand même
extrêmement bien placé et d'autant plus
durant cette période avec les
remboursements donc ça c'est bien autre
point qui est extrêmement important sur
un téléviseur c'est le saut vous avez
deux fois et wat dolby audio mais
également le dts vie tu as la x alors
qu'est ce que ça vous apporte le dts
virtuel x en fait ça va vous permettre
d'avoir un sourd qui va être plus
spatialisé dans votre pièce vous avez
deux haut parleurs de 8 watts on va pas
avoir ici énormément d'eau parleur mais
l'idée c'est que ça vienne spatialisé
leçon que vous ayez une sensation
d'immersion et un son un peu plus
spatiale qu'uniquement une source
thériault provient de votre téléviseur
ça vous permet d'avoir une sensation
deux sont un peu plus en trois
dimensions un peu plus multidirectionnel
et un peu plus enveloppants c'est le
principe il ya tout à connaître ici au
niveau de téléviseurs notamment l'obs
kyling allan loeb scanning se passe ça
vous pas si vous n'êtes pas érudit dans
ce domaine là je vous explique vous là
vous avez un téléviseur en 4k usd mais
si comme moi par exemple vous avez pris
un abonnement netflix moi j'ai pas pris
l'abonnement netflix avec la 4 kg pris
un abonnement netflix en full hd parce
que j'ai pas du tout envie de payer un
abonnement kaka que j'ai trouvé plus
chers et souvent je regarde plus sur un
smartphone sur une tablette mais pas
tout le temps sur mon téléviseur mais si
je le regardais sur mon téléviseur pour
autant j'ai une qualité full hd sur un
écran 4 cas donc ça veut dire qu'il va
me manquer un petit peu d'informations
mon image va être un peu trop petites
mouches que vient faire votre téléviseur
ici de façon intelligente est totalement
transparente pour vous l affaire de
l'ops kyling c'est à dire qu'elle va
prendre la qualité full hd et elle va
l'augmenter elle n'a pas juste étirez
l'image elle va vraiment augmenter la
qualité pour que vous ayez une sensation
d'affichage 4 cas alors que la source du
full hd ça le fait bien évidemment sur
netflix ne se fera sur toutes les
sources full hd ça augmentera la qualité
donc ça c'est intéressant aussi mais ça
ne s'arrête pas là parce que vous avez
un compensateur de mouvement alors ça
fait quoi l'idée ce qu'il faut voir par
exemple c'est que lorsque vous allez
dans des mouvements très rapides des
mouvements à l'image vous pouvez avoir
un petit effet de flou donc ce que va
venir faire ici votre téléviseur c'est
qu'en fait elle va venir créer
virtuellement grâce à un algorithme des
images entre les images et l'avenir
rajouter quelques petites images qu'elle
va venir mettre au milieu ça vient
rajouter un peu en fluidité et vous
allez moins avoir sensation un peu de
flou de bougé ou 2 ou 2 x 2 manque de
précision s'avère rajouter un peu en
précision servir ajouter un peu en
netteté et du coup ça vient augmenter
l'expérience globale et ça c'est
vachement intéressant notamment retrouvé
venir regarder du sport ou des films
d'action et le sport justement
parlons-en parce que vous avez un mode
sport lorsque vous allez venir regarder
un programme sport lorsqu'on est venu
regarder un match de foot c'est ça
notamment pendant la coupe du monde et
bien votre télé elle peut aller
directement plus loin grâce à ce mode
sport samir adapter l'image va venir
pousser la luminosité la saturation bref
vous aurez l'impression d'être encore
plus dans le sport encore plus lorsque
vous regardez ça c'est cool mais puisque
vous dites le sport n'y a pas qu'à
mosport illégalement un mode gaming donc
lorsque vous venez brancher une console
dessus et que vous ne jouez bien vous
passez directement sera vol spécial
c'est le mode gaming ça va réduire
l'input lag ça me permettra d'être plus
réactifs entre ce que vous allez faire
ce qui va se passer et ce qui va
s'afficher sur votre écran et ça tombait
gamer on les veut ces micro secondes
c'est millisecondes permet de gagner du
temps intéressants et puisqu'on se parle
de télé on se parle forcément
télécommande à la télécommande à la un
bénéfice qui est vachement intéressant à
plusieurs bénéfices déjà vous avez
conservé tout votre pavé ici avec vos
numéros pour venir changer de chaîne
très facilement et puis surtout vous
avez tous ses boutons en bas pour avoir
toujours raccourci netflix youtube
molotov canal+ rakuten tv prime vidéo
salto également plus petits ici 10
heures autant dire que là franchement
vous avez le choix en un clic vous
arrivez sur votre programme préféré ou
presque à ces pratiques alors après pour
le reste va venir appelé directement ici
votre assistant vocal ça peut être vide
à voice mais également amazon alexa ou
google assistant le petit bouton pour
revenir à la maison et puis après votre
navigation aussi très simplement quand
surtout que la télécommande et après
pour l'expérience vous avez vida qui
vous permet de naviguer directement
alors là vous avez toutes vos
différentes applications avec les
programmes qu'on va venir vous
recommander a préféré vous avez les apps
principal youtube netflix disney + prime
vidéo molotov canal+ salto également il
y en a plein plein plein plein d'autres
vous avez un catalogue d'applications
pouvait venir en installer ça vous
propose des filles ça vous propose plein
de choses pour venir vous divertir très
facilement donc on a vraiment de tous
les côtés ça c'est très très cool je
vous laisse regarder pas vous même parce
qu'il ya quand même une grosse grosse
grosse grosse grosse grosse grosse
grosse grosse et quand je sais rien a
quand même beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
une très grosse quantité et après vous
avez tous vos paramètres ici pour vous
dire a modifié le mode d'image vous fait
rentrer plus en profondeur après dans
les modes image et maintenir l'échangé
pareil au niveau de l'audio votre réseau
pour connecter bien évidemment votre
télé ici en wifi le recherche de chaînes
automatique si besoin le thème sombre ou
pas les questions d'accessibilité le
système les différents réglages et
l'assistance si vous avez besoin sans
oublier de venir à choisir votre source
et puis si vous avez votre assistant
vous pouvez appuyer pourrait venir lui
parler google assistant choisissez votre
clan ben évidemment votre compte google
qui reliait mais également comme je le
disais amazon avec ça ou alors carrément
vida boys à vous de faire votre choix
vous avec l'embarras si on veut avoir
une idée du résumé ce téléviseur qu'est
ce qu'il faut retenir on arrive ici dans
le cul l'aide directement chassaigne sur
le modèle 55 pouces mais comme je vous
dis il ya d'autre part ça c'est très
très bien on a une télé qui est
extrêmement bien positionnée
vision d'auby audio on a du hdr 10 plus
on a une qualité d'image qui est cool
qui est correct on va avoir bien
évidemment l'ops kyling pour tous vos
formats qui vont pouvoir s'adapter
directement 4k usage des trucs un peu
négative si on veut pas c'est que comme
on est sur une télé qui n'est pas dans
le plus haut de gamme on a pas de passe
câbles donc vous avez votre petit cap
qui l'avenir pendouiller derrière alors
après libre à vous de venir faire un
petit passage propre pour que ça passe
au niveau du pied c'est pas trés
déconnant autre point qui est
intéressant aussi avec ce téléviseur est
bien c'est que cette télécommande avec
tous ces raccourcis sur le bas ça je
dois reconnaître quand même que c'est
hyper hyper hyper canon et puis surtout
le positionnement tarifaire 599 euros
avec les 100 euros remboursé jeudi les
dates j'ai noté là je vous le redis no
télé parce que c'est vachement
intéressant si vous regardez cette vidéo
moment où elle va sortir du 22 juin
jusqu'au 19 juillet prochain seul modèle
55 pouces elle vous tombe à 499 euros
une fois vous avez été remboursés donc
c'est quand même hyper hyper hyper canon
donc ça c'est intéressant si vous avez
des besoins de renouveler votre télé
vous pouvez les chi'ites hisense vous
les avez peut-être déjà vu sur des
matchs de foot mais en tout cas estime
qu'il faut savoir c'est que c'est une
énorme boîte qui fait plein
d'électroménager qui fait des
téléviseurs qui fait plein de produits
tech extrêmement cool et qui est très
innovante donc si vous voulez une telle
est intéressante pour arriver dans le
cul l'aide vous pouvez y aller y ait
aucun problème a vous de me dire ce que
vous en pensez si vous avez des
questions sur ce téléviseur pour y aller
en bas en commentaire c'est ça donc
allez-y ça se passe en bas et puis et
moi je vous embrasse nous donne rendez
vous très bientôt pour continuer à
parler de texte peut-être de télé je
sais pas on verra on va continuer à
découvrir des choses ensemble ça c'est
cool donc à bientôt pour le soin de vous
et je vous embrasse mello ciao
[Musique]